we've lived for a hundred years on the
assumption of if it's on film it's true
yeah and we are about to enter the era
of that not being true hey guys welcome
to a very special episode of the podcast
in can I'm here with Kevin Alaka I'm
gonna allow him to kind of give you the
context I have a series of questions but
this kicks off our interview series at
can something that I wanted to do for a
lot of this audience as the podcast has
grown and become far more 360 obviously
so much grounded in entrepreneurship and
startup culture but over the last half
decade a lot more in the ad world and
the fortune 500 land and what's really
excited about having Kevin on is I think
his organization and and really
ironically what he actually does for a
living I think touches a far majority of
the people listening so I'm super
excited bro
I'm really glad you're here please tell
the vaynernation who you are and what
you do sure so I'm Kevin Alaka I'm the
head of culture and trends at YouTube I
basically work on projects that help
people find and understand what's
popular on YouTube at the end of the day
and I've been tracking trends at YouTube
for for almost nine years now I wrote a
book called videography which looks at
like ways that people interact with
culture and and and interact with video
and how that influences culture and so
basically I work on like on the one side
we do a lot of like consumer stuff
basically how we surface and understand
what's what's popular on YouTube and
then on the other side like I am here
because a lot of times people won't
understand in this world what's going on
in creativity what's going on on YouTube
and I mean this world about this world
needs to pay way more attention yeah
yeah you agree with that I do I mean I
think I think there's a we were at this
phase a few years ago where it was like
okay there's a lot of audience here so
we're gonna like we're gonna pay
attention to that audience but not take
a second to understand what they're
watching or why they're watching it and
now we're kind of entering that this
other phase where I think everybody's
starting to see like oh I like to
understand how to reach that audience I
need
understand why they're there what
they're doing there sure who they care
about and like you know that like I give
this talk this week about this and in
many ways but like we we're so used to
making assumptions and value judgments
about about creativity and about content
and and what people should like or
shouldn't like and it's audacious a lot
of us it's audacious yeah I mean I think
you know so let's take a step back what
kind of kid were you then where'd you
grow up
yeah like where you into Star Wars or
like selling Jolly Ranchers so that I
see up to ear your ear ringing oh those
are just those are just uh birthmarks
yeah all right damn it I was like why'd
you have two earrings in the same year I
was super fired up I was like I went to
it immediately what I did I did grow up
in my in like north of Miami in South
Florida okay which is it what can I
please Hollywood floor yes that's where
all the Russians have gone do you know
about this like all my parents
generation Russians have all moved to
this Hollywood Florida means like it's
about to be the Brighton Beach of
Florida I was part of the way of where
everybody's Italian parents moved to
flow case oh so like that's how make sex
that's how I was born there yep and I
grew up in Souls 18 that was like I got
it what kind of kid really I was like I
kept trying to figure out what like in
between how old are you right now
um I'm 35 keep going so I was sitting
between cultures in a way because I was
growing up everybody I grew up we grew
up with was like kids a first generation
immigrant said nice from Latin America
and things but my family was from New
York and they were you know the
italian-american so I just was like I'm
gonna be into metal like cuz like that's
what you decided thing you should be
into and you're in yeah yeah South
Florida cuz I just like water if you
want to be counterculture yeah clue you
know so when you get into an Iron Maiden
and [ __ ] yeah and so like you know and
then like it took I like it took me a
long time to her embrace that I just
really actually loved what I was around
which is all the hip-hop scene that was
happening down there interesting and by
the time I went to come literally you
were that kind of dude like you wanted
to be countercultural so like you didn't
want to be into hip-hop like everybody
else
yeah I love that like yeah I go I know
people like that
Steve on one
no you know but now I'm like man who
Tang was so good so good it took me so
long to sort of really appreciate some
of these things so that we were into
music yeah and yeah you know I really
wanted to work into movies for a long
long time I did theater and speech and
debate and stuff and nerd stuff and but
you were but you were outward yeah yeah
totally and I was just I was I you know
scooch in debate
historically nerd stuff but it's so
crazy now that everybody wants to be
like everybody like all these 18 year
olds think I'm cool cuz I give
motivational speeches and they're all
like hitting me up and they're like I
want to join the debate team I want to
join the speech and I'm like my god this
was the nerdiest [ __ ] when I was a kid
and now just how the world moves I mean
one of us invaluable if you think about
you right now you're like textbook
influence every kid 14 wants to be an
influencer yeah on earth yeah and
literally being into film speech and
debate would be like a real good idea
you like set the tone for the framework
of this is actually kind of meta so I
love asking questions like this you're
sitting this incredibly important
position at YouTube which is really
outside of Instagram the other what the
two places where the manifestation of
influencer the way every
fourteen-year-old thinks and literally
the framework of what you grew up
actually is probably the blueprint a lot
of them should be thinking about it's
true I think I mean like that's that
those years that I spent and I did
comedy for a bid to and I liked those
years that I spent doing that stuff like
really shaved I think comedy improv
sketch skit yeah same [ __ ] though at
some level yeah totally but it's all
about like trying to understand an
audience in a way like that's that's
exactly what me a long time to figure
out that or like I was really just
obsessed with why people like stuff and
that is professionally my job now is
like for you how did you end up in this
position it's pretty weird
you've been that YouTube for nine years
yes so before that I was a comedy writer
for a bit of an imposed okay and then I
worked a media Bistro very welcome there
like very well yeah of course I was
there television news industry editor
for a bit like after Stelter wouldn't
you worked you work you might you worked
for Jonah huff um we did this there is
this thing called a dealer and Paul
Paul's there and I was there but yeah
Barry Diller and Arianna did this thing
called 23-6 which is like a political
satire yes I remember and I was my first
job in New York I was in a tutorial
system worked my way up to associate
editor whatever
election run up and right afterwards
like I didn't really appreciate the
economics of it at the time so I was
like baffled when the thing fell apart
two years later now I'm like of course
but you know that's about to happen in
the world again pretty soon everyone's
about to be baffled yeah so how's my
director consumer brand not doing well
even though I'm losing money on every
customer I choir work but for the law as
long as I did but we Berry has deep
pockets but these so like I was I knew a
lot about like about pop culture from
working in that job by the way real
quick on that just is now selfish for my
audience back to bury his deep pockets
it's actually not that it's actually a
lot of what I think about I have so many
things micro fail but the macro always
works yeah you know if you think about
IC think about all that like they're
doing so much that like all they need is
like three or four wins like 23 six is
right it's just you know timing and the
economy and all that didn't allow them
to see it through totally but it's
really fascinating when you see those
when you look at an icon like berry or
others like they're always trying things
and and nobody here knows about 23:6 but
everybody knows about the biggest dating
ecosystem on the internet everybody
knows about all the other things that
they've accomplished CollegeHumor know
those iconic things so like you know
there were and there were a lot of
things that we were doing back then like
these like kind of political supercut
things like that kind of remix style
that like YouTube had just launched so
like there was are you doing these fakes
yet no no okay P rock what are you gonna
make deep fakes of me saying [ __ ] like I
love Tom Brady that by the way for
everybody knows that will never happen
so when that will be a deep fake by the
way that's by the way just like to be
completely scattered like I like to be
this deep fake thing really is
fascinating like if you think about a
eyes advancement like I'm like wow we're
talking about a half decade from now
where this shit's gonna be perfect and
now what are we just only in a place
where like like you could you know it's
so funny the openness of the internet
was something I understood I think we're
gonna see a big like I almost feel like
I'm just gonna be live streaming at all
times to prove its me and what I have to
say like I actually everybody thinks
it's gonna close I even just started
saying the closeness my
counter move to the closeness is
complete on this yeah I mean there's if
I scream all every minute of my life
there should be no debate if I ever said
it cuz it's document that if I did or
did it I can prove that it in you've
been watching at all times
some Truman Show [ __ ] me rock you ready
to sleep in the same bed as me but yeah
there's so many I mean there's so many
crazy because we've what's your take on
that
well I mean we've been we've spent this
time we've like I'm gonna say we I mean
all of us we've all spent this era of
like being used to the idea of like oh
if it's on video it happened right and
so like eyewitness footage I mean that's
the thing that scares me especially from
international places where we don't we
don't actually have a window in
necessarily because there's not a free
press and like now we're gonna be having
we're have this new dynamic that's
coming in where we have to evaluate
everything on this new level yeah and
we're like not the world is not ready
for that
no because what as you're as you know
that means people are just gonna go into
their prejudices yeah by having the
ability to say deep fake now you can
basically say that didn't happen right
like this horrific [ __ ] of the
police and Phoenix if you want to be on
the side of the racism you can just say
that's a [ __ ] video yeah that
[ __ ] hurts
I agree listen this is work there listen
there's a complete restructuring of our
society in our faces right now
nationalism on the on the rise
deep to your point I mean that's a
that's a great way to put it we've lived
for a hundred years on the assumption of
if it's on film it's true yeah and we
are about to enter the era of that not
being true now there's there's another
side of this which is kind of
interesting and like I could be my
sister right now like I'm just caught up
image free right now and my sister's
talking there's another sister Elizabeth
is the greatest humanize good good
there's another thing that's happening
that's on the other side of this which
is a much more kind of creative side
where we're seeing out of like places
like Japan like like actual creators
like on Cameron personal call virtual
youtubers da we're all you know that are
all artificial and it's actually
allowing people to do other more
creative stuff allowing them to voice
themselves in ways they wouldn't there's
always good about you know so it's like
it's interesting so you were right or
did it it that it and then what a job
open up at YouTube and you're like I'm
interested I was interested because
obviously like at that point I was 2010
YouTube was I was loved viral videos I
everybody did
and and and but YouTube few remember do
you remember uh Narnia and and Magnolia
like so I was on YouTube so early yes
February yes so I I'm so pissed I wasn't
documenting back then you Yahoo Video
and YouTube independent yeah both flew
me out to California like the first time
I ever did like beef even before
Facebook and Twitter I flew out and they
were asking me questions about why I was
making 20 minute videos yeah you gotta
love this this is crazy I could see Dee
Brock parking up I never talked about
this I was so early and I was goin so
long for him that besides like rocket
boom and Zay Frank were like doing like
five minutes and renetto and there was
like yeah like some real early people
first of all as you know no million
viewed videos yeah none like like when
Narnia and like Magnolia cupcakes like
when that exploded on SNL clips and they
were getting like a million people were
like blown away like I mean like such a
golden thing like that was just like
every video that did like when I did
Conan in July of 2007 like literally
every youtuber emailed me and said
you're doing this for us
be like besides Perez Hilton nobody had
done a mainstream media thing so when I
did that skit no7 literally like the 39
the 88 like youtubers that matters
that's how many there were
we're like hey go do it for us you know
like you know and so it was super early
but real quick they flew me out and they
were asking me questions like why are
you making 20 minute videos yeah as then
like no like you shouldn't be making
them like only one-minute videos work
yeah I mean there's there's a long
history youtuber I mean I've been there
for nine years of of Pete of even the
people who work there being like we
think this technology is for this and
then you going and doing that and being
like oh actually it could be for that
that's what's fun being a platform you
get to watch and that's what you do in
the macro yeah you know it's funny what
you do for a living is probably in some
weird way the thing I enjoy most doing
for a living even though I don't do it
like officially yeah a lot
my comes from reading and listening and
just reading comments how how do you
think about your process and figuring
out you know inevitably the biggest
brands in the world other organizations
that YouTube wants to do business with
or wants to help are asking you
questions like what is happening what is
popping like how do you how do you not
make that just a math equation it's you
know cuz I know you don't ya know my
boss otherwise anybody could do it
she's like she said to me once and I
think what's all the time she's like how
can we just take the feeds of stuff that
you guys look at and make give them
everybody else so they can have the same
insight so you have it was like honestly
that's not the best insight I have is
this person who like is watching stuff
all day and then she and this other
person together like talk about what
they've just seen and they draw some
connectional contextual connection and
then we go look at the data to verify
whether there's actually something there
or not and like there's creativity is
really hard to quantify actually like I
mean there's it's you can do this like
possible well of course yeah I mean
sorry I'd say I should say there are
certain aspects of creativity that you
would expect to be able to go on and I
are actually not and of course like you
know there's we've had this debate all
the time I can you actually like
artificially like create create the
create is that even possible but you can
do a lot of stuff post game yeah that's
what people to understand post game
we're all heroes oh that bit like we put
everyday we're like oh that wasn't good
yeah cuz the audience gets this it's the
pregame work totally and then you do
something that someone else does that
thing and then like a year later there's
a taxonomy that is been invented that
released those things we've seen this
music for a long time obviously like yes
there was no like language for how to
talk about Punk when fungus were
starting or whatever and now it's like
what do they call ice is thinner I don't
got it I just don't know yeah yeah yeah
but like I think like you just an even
like Popeye was having us to be like
because there's this whole we're having
this debate right now me and my music
trans person about like whether pop
music is that change completely or does
it even exist anymore and like the
things we think of as pop art as popular
as anything this is what this is what
intellectual humans waste but I think
it's it's it all speaks to this thing
which is not about we have not a waste
of time which is like if you if you
realize that when you look at everything
you start to say oh like I can't just
right now go and like say X Y & Z is
popping so we're gonna do we're gonna do
another thing we're gonna get us you
know based on that thing there's still
as such a strong element of
like I you know creators all the time
people that you know like they're like
okay everybody's trying to work the game
trying to like figure out the thing to
titles and thumbnails like friends like
above everything else besides all those
optimizations like you have to have such
a strong independent voice like to be
able to break through on stuff and
that's like is the singular reason I
think that I've had some success is I'm
not good at growth hacking yeah I mean
it so by a shooing that you're just
focused in on you and yes yeah uh-huh
and I don't consume anybody else's
content I mean we get nothing I would
scale like I watched New York Jets
football yeah and I read comments from
the content I put out so it's if it
hasn't been responded to something that
you're already saying you're insular
luck and somehow I still know what's
going on with Meg the stallion or like
the comments your commenters are just
and then and then humans right Magnus
tallying cuz a Mike Boyd a human that I
have who has an ear to the scree and
he's like what you know he's curating
music for me to listen to so hip-hop I
have a human infrastructure in place and
then I have a funny ear and it's always
been that way bon'te like a lot of the
people I liked before people like them
Master P Bone Thugs there's been so many
things that have happened in my career
of like just being a consumer of being
early on people so that's that combo but
a lot of the other stuff like it it's
it's serendipity when I'm Twitter is
very good for me because it's insular in
a different way comments on YouTube and
comments on Instagram stay within a
vortex on Twitter
somebody will reply to me about
something and make a reference to
something and it's right there yeah and
so it's there's a I think Twitter this
is like the first time I've articulated
it I think Twitter helps me discover
some stuff a little bit more than I
realize but it's very very inserts funny
I just spoke to a bunch of the craters
on an off-the-record combo where Casey
nice that was interviewing me and it was
like the it's great so you know who was
in there right so the big thing I told
them that really broke through and a
bunch of them hit me up who had not
known who I was especially the younger
crew I told him like hey you're becoming
a [ __ ] creature of the [ __ ]
yeah I'm like you you all know the
videos that are gonna work you can bang
those out you already know like you're
gonna become unhappy plus you've evolved
like when you were 16 to 19
especially the youngsters right like
right now I'm pretty locked in like
thirty five to forty three is like
there's some edge work but [ __ ]
fifteen to twenty two there's [ __ ]
foundational work of who you're gonna be
some of these kids start off as [ __ ]
makeup this and now they like don't even
wanna they want no makeup they think
it's clean lately and like I was really
pushing them and this really resonated
I'd love to get your thought on this
that's why I'm setting it up as a
question I said make a video that you
know won't work that isn't made for the
algorithm in the growth but that you
just actually want to make and some of
them have and it really did well and
they're really happy and if I felt like
I made a little bit of a difference it's
starting to be a drum I'm starting to
beat more dots yeah I mean I think
because I think it is not as formula
driven as people want to believe it yeah
there's a comfort in that and I think in
a way and like those people that have
success and rely on those formulas
there's certain things about those
formulas that are allowing them to
express certain parts of themselves that
really resonate with people whatever but
like I actually think it they you get to
a point where you're like well I have to
keep doing that thing to be able to
succeed mister mister ponyville just
broken them all over and over mister
beasts is creative above and beyond just
the fact that he's great a thumbnails
100 percent 100 percent and you know the
one thing that you just sort of
reference in the missile what you're
saying is that like there is this and
this is fascinating to me it's like
there's this group the peak if you're 19
right now you were 5 when YouTube lunch
you grew up watching you people like you
yeah not me cuz I was selling alcohol
but like but yes yeah you know you're
right that era of people yeah watching
that so like what is what you make look
like you call of Fame no but we should
aside that well the same [ __ ] way all
the other [ __ ] [ __ ] things do the
NBA the NBA Hall things a [ __ ] joke
I'm just basically trying to figure out
which Hall of Fame's I can sneak into so
that was that let's move on alright so
what you know there's a lot of people
listening right now who do want to pop
or do want to get like let's be very
selfish for my audience what are some
hot takes observation like diarrhea of
the mouth of like some things you're
seeing
are completely predicated on a potential
first mover advantage because one great
thing I love about my audience is
because I suffocate the [ __ ] of inaction
this is not just a place to get
motivation it is it's a place to get
motivated by the way if you're listening
and you haven't done [ __ ] and you just
use me for a quick motivation you and
you use me as an occasion as a make
pretend to doing [ __ ] this is a public
service announcement like stop [ __ ]
listening to me and [ __ ] do something
or continue to listen to me but do
something because d-roc you've seen that
whole group of people who love to tweet
Gary I stopped watching you I favourite
them and 90% of them are just listening
now to a worse version of me and still
not doing [ __ ] so give me some hot takes
that might be valuable for the audience
before we bounce first thing yeah make
stuff like there's people like I have
this because so much what you see now
feels like it's very packaged and edited
and pristine like there's a there's a
sort of thing I got to start there but
like that's the lowest stakes thing you
could do is just put up something and
see how it see how people all 1,000
episodes of Wine Library TV I did no
audio no lighting I literally look like
I was a hostage like literally when you
like watched if you haven't seen it a
lot of you don't even know about my wine
videos go to YouTube by the way biggest
mistake of my career happened one of the
first people on youtube viddler a
competitive video platform gave me seven
percent of the company think about how
hot I was on YouTube in year one they me
seven percent of the company to go
exclusively on visitor plus it worked
for me I was so long what Villa had was
an IP a patent on tagging within the
stream in the bottom because people were
complaining in my comments I didn't just
lead for the money because I rarely do
it was it was Gary you talk so much in
between reviewing the wines I'm here
just for the reviewing wines
so what viler did was like at the bottom
of the player you could see four little
dot exactly it was [ __ ] amazing
anyway one of the biggest mistakes I
made was leaving the platform but like
like dude like if you go watch if you go
to youtube right now because I think
Villiers so down that the videos are
gone like if you go to youtube right now
I made sure all the archives went up
there they don't have a lot of views for
that reason but I
like a hostage yeah but it's like you
the other stuff comes as you like it
turns out that the other things the
production value yeah it's like matters
but not as much as like have held Iran
d-roc that was one of the biggest things
you learned coming into my world right I
admit it okay good admit it again for my
own happiness what else did you learn do
you rock no good
alright so production value I permit to
make that's a big one for me like just
[ __ ] make next is the other thing is
you know you talk about work around
something that you really actually are
passionate about and care about or
deeply knowledgeable don't do you
believe people yeah you have to really
care about it because because we're deep
in knowledge any hating you'll quit
exactly yeah it's not a thing that you
could just like get in and be like I'm
gonna do this for six months we'll see
what happens and then like you know my
I'll be a big star after that like
that's not how that game works at all
ninety-nine percent don't you know yeah
you gotta be in it and you got to want
to do it all the time you kind of want
it's like people ask me all the time now
about writing books so what do I need to
do to write a book is like pick
something you want to be obsessed with
for five years have you ever read is
that have you ever read crush it I want
to send it to you I'll tell you why I
think you're gonna [ __ ] that I wrote in
2008 because it's like so far completely
on your thesis keep going I mean and
then so you have those like if you if
you just start making stuff and it's
built around the thing you care about
you're already like halfway to getting
where you need to go then you got to pay
attention on what you got it's like all
the basic stuff you got it there's the
amount of analytics you have available
to you is is incredible most of it
doesn't matter you got to pick a couple
of things that matter to you what people
like what sort your attention look like
what are the thumbnails that people are
clicking on you gotta like pay attention
to those things because that helps
that's not just like optimizing for some
thing that is just telling you what
people are interested in do you see a
lot of people who are an incredible at
the thumbnail and title [ __ ] but once
the people walk in the door the actual
content because they're not passionate
or talented is so garbage that they even
know they're good at growth hacking also
fail yeah I mean it happens all the time
actually because the like the way that
just like in a way the way that the
YouTube algorithm is designed is are
around retention and like watch time
right it's about right length of
engagement so people coming in there
bailing your
we're gonna be able to survive and the
anting served on the end yeah I mean
we're it worked they used to work back
in the day yeah no I know things have to
has changed a lot since then because you
know good YouTube cares about its end
user yeah of course it's all about like
giving people what they want in a way
and that's what's what's been buzzing in
the halls give some shoutouts to some
people doing some creative stuff in the
last six months to a year what's been a
video a creator and I listen obviously
this is completely flavor of the month
this could be somebody walking by in
your Hall and like but you know I'm sure
everybody that works at YouTube has
their you know plate of favorites and
different creators but like what's been
in the last month or two like catching
people's attention so examples good here
but Emma Chamberlain Joanna sedia
they're both young they're both
rejecting a lot of the things this goes
into the lore talking about before about
people grew up watching other stuff yes
like these are people who like they
don't wear makeup yes it like sloppy
editing if it's their voices are so
authentic and fun and like you just love
the [ __ ] out of everything they make
like they're and they're my team is just
like obsessed with good and I think what
they're what they're doing is they're
basically saying they and like you know
you how are they together they're doing
separate things but the same [ __ ] yeah
they're think they're both in the same
there's a part of crew young people do
they know each other I mean do they [ __ ]
with each other like they give like DAPs
like you know we're different we're not
friends but like I [ __ ] with you like on
the same you see the world the way I did
and their fans definitely have like
that's but do they like are they like
like let's start this adventure [ __ ]
okay well let's get both of them on the
podcast together we'll just [ __ ] it I'm
the original [ __ ] one piece of [ __ ]
editing [ __ ] voice powerful as [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] granddaddy of these two
ladies you want to talk about flavor of
the month will nas ex and yes an old
town of course and if he came to the
office and I said I got to chat them for
a little bit about like his like the
Prophet who Danny nothing bad where was
this fatty he's like it was just so
intuitive like he just like yeah I made
50 memes of with the song in the
background a bunch of them blew up and
now I've had single like yeah this was
and he it wasn't like he was like he
just got lucky he like knew how to work
yeah you know knew how to work yeah all
these all these these these people are
deeper strategists like are they gonna
is he gonna be one-hit wonder
it's gonna happen it's like well I don't
know but he's he knows how to know new
you you know he's not going through
because he's got the tools in his belt
he has some hits it's the same reason I
know I'll always win I'm both on both
the actor and the producer and the
distributor and when you are the
distributor the one-hit wonder that we
were leaving innovating can you be a
one-hit wonder anymore when you could
build your own audience and you know a
certain point right and then what's the
redefinition of that right is like are
we all half hit hunt one wonders because
it amortizes out yeah what else about
something I'm passionate about I'm
getting really hot on the idea of hiring
a lot of 50 to 90 year olds starting a
incubator in a retirement home I'm
always looking for white spaces we're
talking about a lot of inclusion in our
society now which I'm very happy about I
think the one group we're not talking
about is people that are over 60 yeah so
so anything interesting what's like
intuitively I feel like YouTube's mature
enough now is there like some 86 year
old crushing for the other 86 year olds
on YouTube we've seen a lot of we've
seen a lot of older creators now like
copying us but it's actually
interestingly we're seeing a lot of it
in India in other countries there's
something Germany I've seen it I've seen
you know you see America is [ __ ]
[ __ ] and the sages and there's a
there's a lot of you know people who are
revered in their community for their
expertise like cooking right for example
that like oh yeah why not like you know
why not hear from this a 90 year old
woman how she cooks these recipes like
that's exactly what I want to hear
probably all these only people I wanted
to hear from as a kid was the
grandparents of my friends like
literally history was the only class I
was good at and I always gravitated
towards the elderly yeah and I think
there's like a there's a because they
have not grown up with these
technologies my grandfather is a hundred
and one he's on the internet every day
he's emailing me he's checking his
stocks he's like you know I'll come home
and I'll be like what he's like explain
to me the cloud and it's like oh my god
you know but he's like wants to know he
like wants to everything it's not like I
think that we have this these these like
do you have beliefs these stereotypes
people are like let's like focus on
something important tell me everything
about your grandfather's hundredth
birthday party Oh was awesome was down
in Florida he Hey so it is 95th birthday
party he was like hey I don't
great-grandkids that's not cool so he
like took the mic and was like [ __ ] you
get this get the [ __ ] hit and like
all the raw like hundredth birthday
there's four great grandkids like
sitting at the table you know like this
everybody's married like it's a whole
other ballgame as the kids warrant your
word
it matters do you know it was really
well it was really awesome but I mean he
was that he was at the World's Fair when
they debuted the TV and I just like now
easy yeah what about you what's your
favorite story from your grandpa like
what is it like how does your grandpa
roll like this he rolled uh you guys are
complaining about [ __ ] the wrong milk
and [ __ ] coffee and like we went
through the [ __ ] Depression does he
roll is like sit down kid like how does
he roll he's just like he's a he's a
timeless person yeah yeah and like he's
like you know he fought in World War two
and like you know what Bronze Star saw
some [ __ ] like I imagine doesn't talk
about he's never like oh man you don't
you know yeah a war you know he never
says that's right he just wants
everybody to succeed and wants them to
be smart what do we end with what uh
what didn't we cover here like as one
final part for all the aspiration that
is listening I think I mean your
audience is mostly us or do you have
like a know it's pretty global I think
the thing that is super interesting to
me is like how much we're seeing cross
culture stuff yes and there's like both
the you have both things that are like a
hyperlocal and that only makes sense in
certain markets and you have stuff
that's playing out across different
markets to that point I apologize are
you paying attention to what's going on
on Netflix from where we're starting to
see truly breakout hits that are you
know there's that show dark in Germany
that is like subtitle than just like a
global phenomenon even though it's super
similar to stranger things which is
super cool like you know I think I think
what YouTube and Netflix are showing I
actually think it's the end of American
pop culture dominance I mean you're
already seeing it like never in your or
my generation would we see k-pop stars
dominate 12 year old blonde girls in
Florida you know and so I think it's a
really interesting time is that where
you're referring to I mean II to the top
10 songs globally on YouTube eliezer
Spanish you know like that's like not
something that we would have seen and
obviously part of that is like Latin
America blowing up oh yeah on usage
online but I think you're just seeing
like there's a more of an appetite for
perspectives from different cultures
right now and for creativity coming from
different places and I think if you if
you just are the type of person who's
like me who wants to know what's
happening and like be like kind of the
best you gotta be you got to be looking
what's happening at it no it's the best
I mean Latin trap has been something
I've been like watch of like three years
and it just been super interesting to
watch it explode the the Ubik like the
the global like essence of hip-hop is
fascinating to me that like hip-hop
works everywhere you know rules the
world yeah
rest in peace snip ah this was great
yeah thank you so much forever
yeah thanks for your having a great week
and we'll see you soon yeah thank you
thank you keep listening everyone please
leave your comments this is a little bit
of a new format I'd love to get your
feedback on that hit me up on Twitter
all the global listeners since we're not
American dominated I hope you guys enjoy
we'll see you next time
thanks for listening